[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Please
welcome to the Talks at Google
stage, Mr. Jerry Buting.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
JERRY BUTING: Sure.
Thank you.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: So the book
is "Illusion of Justice--
Inside Making a Murder and
America's Broken System."
I'd like to start by asking you,
if you could, in your words,
define for us justice
and how you think
that the system in
America has strayed
from what is actually justice.
JERRY BUTING: Well,
it's a good question.
We could probably spend the
whole day talking about what
justice is and isn't.
The one thing that sometimes
people lose sight of
is that this is
a human endeavor.
And whenever there are
human beings involved,
there are going to be differing
opinions about what's just
and what's not.
Certainly somebody who's
the victim of a crime
is going to have one view.
The person who's accused of a
crime is going to have another.
But real justice
should be somewhere
in the middle where the people
as a whole feel like justice
has been served by--
and that's why in our country,
we have so many processes.
And due process is
such an important thing
so that if somebody is allowed
to fully present a defense,
and if the jury is
really fair, justice
should be served in most cases.
Now there are times where
juries make mistakes,
and innocent people
get convicted.
And one of the
fallacies is that, well,
if a jury gets it wrong,
then all you've got to do
is wait for the appeal.
The appellate court
will correct it.
And unfortunately, that's not
the way the system's set up.
The system is set
up really to ensure
that judgments are final.
And they make it
very, very difficult
for you to reopen
a case if there has
been a miscarriage of justice.
It's interesting, in the
UK, they call it that.
They don't call it
wrongful convictions.
They call it a
miscarriage of justice.
They have commissions that are
called miscarriage of justice
commissions where the train
sort of goes off the tracks,
something happens, and the
wrong person is convicted,
or there's corruption
that's allowed
to seep into the system.
And ultimately, there
are so many things
tugging and pulling at
justice, whether it's
the media that has one agenda
that they're trying to sell.
They used to be trying
to sell newspapers.
Most people don't
buy those anymore.
So it's clickbait where
they're trying to get somebody
to click on their article.
But that may not
really be the truth.
And certainly it
wouldn't be just
if that was what the whole
system was designed to protect.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: So
if it does come down
to justice being about--
it's almost the greatest
good for the greatest number.
Everybody sort of
feels good that justice
was served in that.
How does that
align with the rule
of law, which is a much more
black and white situation?
There's not a lot of room for
opinion if the law is the law.
JERRY BUTING: Well,
again, part of it
comes down to you
have to first start
with the fundamental
understanding
that these are human beings
that are running the system
and that there will be mistakes.
And I have a quote in
my book from John Adams
before the Revolutionary
War actually
when he defended-- he
was a defense attorney,
and he defended British
soldiers who were accused
of massacre of colonists.
And in his closing argument, he
sort of paraphrased something
that goes even long back
before him to black men
and been traced even far enough
back in the English common law
than that.
And it's the idea that
it really is better
that 10 guilty people go free
than that one innocent person
be convicted.
Why?
Well, as John Adams put it, it's
because the crimes and misdeeds
are so numerous
that you can never
prosecute every single one
of them and get a conviction.
But if you convict
the innocent--
and particularly in
a death penalty case,
if you convict the innocent
and the innocent person
is executed or faces
the death penalty--
then that really
upsets all of society,
because then the innocent
person will say, well,
if innocence isn't
enough to protect me
from being executed
or being imprisoned
for the rest of my life, why
should I obey the law at all?
And once that idea
takes root in society,
you have a complete
disrespect for the law.
And the rule of law
will not exist at all.
So those are some of the
fundamental principles
that even though the rule of
law is very, very important,
it's supposed to err on the
side of protecting the innocent,
rather than what I think all
too often nowadays people
think is, well, if an innocent
person is convicted here there
and gets 20 years or 30 years
or whatever, that's just kind
of the cost of doing business.
We'd rather have that than have
some terrorist running free.
So things have sort of
flipped upside down.
And part of that may
also be why there
is such a mistrust in certain
communities in this country--
people of color or
recent immigrants
who feel that the law
isn't fair to them
and doesn't apply to them.
The rule of law
doesn't apply to them.
There is this growing distrust
in the community of the police
and the law as a whole.
And there's a lot
of reasons for that.
But some of it, I
think, comes down
to the loss of
this understanding
that we really do need to err
on the side of the innocent.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: We
touched on the fallibility
of the human element and then
the shift and the change.
The very sort of
definitive statement
of "America's
Broken System," I'd
like to dive into that
a little bit more.
JERRY BUTING: Sure.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: What are some
of the major ways that elements
of the justice system have
just fallen apart and failed
inside the United States?
JERRY BUTING: Well,
one of the biggest
is the chronic underfunding
of indigent defense.
The vast majority of people--
you can go even beyond that
and say, why is it that 80% of
the people who are prosecuted
can't afford their own lawyers?
Is it because poor people commit
crimes, and rich people don't?
No.
Why is it that we focus
so much of our resources
on prosecuting poor people?
They're the grist of
the conviction mill
in our criminal justice system.
We lock them up for
ridiculously long times.
We have 5% of the world's
population in America
but 20% of the incarcerated
people in the world--
an incredible imbalance,
shocking statistic.
And that includes North
Korea and Russia, China--
any kind of repressive regimes.
And partly, it's the length
of sentences that we have.
And that gets disproportionately
applied to the poor.
So when 80%, 85% of the people
who are charged and processed
in our criminal justice system
can't afford their own lawyer,
you have to ask why that is.
Secondly--
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Well, I
want to ask now why that is.
JERRY BUTING: Well, there's
a whole lot of things.
Part of it is sort of
almost a vicious circle--
a self-fulfilling prophecy
that happens where--
you see it in Steven
Avery's case, quite frankly,
and other small towns
all over the world
and certainly all
of our country--
where you often
will get somebody
who the police look at as
sort of on the wrong side
of the tracks.
Maybe he's sort of a
smart mouth teenager.
And if you've ever seen
a cop with an attitude,
they don't like that.
And so then that
kid gets hauled in.
And he gets his
first minor record.
And then that
happens repeatedly.
And then there's an
engendering of disrespect.
So then maybe he's
kicked out of school.
Or even go before that,
you've got poor people
who are evicted from homes.
And then they pull
them out of the school
that they're comfortable
in, and now they're
into a different school.
And maybe they're going to fail
academically because of that,
because they're constantly
being evicted and moved
into different schools.
And they don't have
that kind of support.
And then that's going to make
it more difficult for them
to get the education,
to get the jobs.
And it's more complicated
than I'm getting into
and that we can
talk about today.
But back to your
first question, which
is, what's the
single biggest issue?
If there is one
single big issue,
I would say it's the
lack of resources
given to people who need to
have somebody defend them.
So it's not entirely
just the defense side.
The prosecutors are overworked.
The prosecutors are underfunded.
Courts are underfunded as well.
But just to give
you one example,
in Wisconsin, if
you're appointed
a staff-salaried
public defender,
like I started off
as, you will get
one level of care
and representation,
generally better than if you
don't get one of those lawyers
and you're instead appointed
a private attorney on a list,
because those people only
get paid $40 an hour.
And out of that,
they're supposed
to pay their rent, their
utilities, their staffs--
secretaries, assistants,
if they have any--
when the average
overhead, and not
in a place like New York
City where it's a lot higher,
but the average overhead is
probably somewhere $50 to $60
an hour.
So the quality of
lawyers that you
get willing to take those
cases, you get what you pay for.
You can't get a plumber
to come to your house
for less than $100.
And to pay lawyers
only $40 an hour--
when I started in 1981 in
Wisconsin, it was $45 an hour.
1981 dollars-- that's about
$5 or $6 now after inflation.
So you end up with people
like poor Brendan Dassey had
who are just trying
to cut a deal
and think their client's guilty.
But there's a story in the book
where I fell prey to that, too.
I was a staffed lawyer.
And sometimes the pressures
that public defenders have
of having to continually
open new cases,
whether you close them or
not, you make snap judgments.
And in one particular story--
I won't get into it right
now, but it's in the book--
I made the snap judgment
that a client was guilty,
and I was wrong.
And my later wife
proved me wrong.
And what that told
me was that I needed
to get out of that
kind of a rat race
where I could practice
law in a better way, where
I could control my workflow.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Yeah.
It seems interesting
to note, as we
spoke about earlier,
the black and whiteness
of the rule of law.
But we've moved into justice
kind of as a business,
it sounds like you're
saying, to where
the quality next to a price
tag is actually relevant.
So instead of a
situation where we're
taking the evidence that we
have, the evidence as it's
presented, and applying
that to the law
and coming to the
correct answer,
the quality has skewed the
justice system away from that.
JERRY BUTING: Well, it's partly
because our system is set up
to be-- it's an
adversary system.
The idea is that if you
have-- and this goes way,
way way back into the
English common law--
that if you have reasonably
equal, competent advocates
on both sides as
adversaries advocating
for one side or the
other and then there's
a neutral jury or
judge in the middle,
the truth will come out that
way, because you can always--
think about when somebody tells
you their side of the story.
And you hear it, and
it sounds believable
until you hear maybe the
other side of the story.
You start thinking,
well, maybe not.
And if you have advocates for
both sides and they're equal,
then that's the best
way to get at the truth.
At least, that's the
English and American system.
There are other
parts of the world
that use different inquisitorial
types of techniques.
But what's happened is there
is a huge imbalance where
the prosecutors, even
though they're underfunded,
they still have
vastly more resources
and money to put to a
case than the defense.
The Avery case is
another example
where the prosecution
can just call up
the FBI, multimillion dollar
budget, and stop everything
and focus on that one case.
Defense can't do that.
And in the majority
of cases, there's
this really huge imbalance
where the defense
is no longer an equal party
in that adversary system.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Interesting.
JERRY BUTING: And even if
you've got the dream team,
you're still not ever going
to be completely match
the resources of the
government, because after all,
they're just using your
money-- taxpayers' money.
There's no end to that, right?
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Or they just go
print some more, and it's fine.
JERRY BUTING: Yeah, right.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: So it does bring
up another interesting thing
that I would like to talk, about
which is judges and juries.
And I think I want to start
with the judges' side of it.
In the ideal presentation
of the system,
you have a neutral judge.
But you've talked before
in other appearances
about jaded judges
or judges who are
beholden to an electorate,
especially state judges.
They're all elected positions.
JERRY BUTING: Right.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: When we
get into elected judges,
how much does the
popularity contest
affect justice being served?
And then when I say
that, what I mean
is, are we accurately
applying the rule of law
through the eyes of the judges,
or are the judges bending more
toward the will of the people?
And if that's the
case, because they
don't want to lose
their elected--
aren't they applying what
the people in that area
want as their laws?
JERRY BUTING: They might be.
But the system is set up
with the understanding
that the people,
the populace might
be swayed by whatever is
the politically correct lens
of the time or the
passions of the moment,
rather than dispassionately
applying the rule of law.
So this case-- another example--
when the Steven Avery case
was in the pretrial setting,
because of the special
prosecutor's press
conference and the way
the media was covering it,
he was easily the most hated
man in the state, easily,
at least as much as
Jeffrey Dahmer ever was--
more so probably, because
even after Jeffrey Dahmer,
they tried to get a
ballot, a referendum
to reinstate the death
penalty in Wisconsin, which
hadn't happened since 1853--
the longest continuous
period of time without it.
They had never had
a referendum on it.
It was just they had
tried a number of times,
after Jeffrey Dahmer
in particular.
Didn't work-- but after the
press conference in this case
where Mr. Avery was portrayed
as this monster who did this
horrible, brutal rape,
murder, mutilation,
torture of this woman--
all of which was
totally unsupported
by the evidence--
in fact, disproven
by the physical evidence.
He became so hated
that the legislature
put a referendum on the ballot.
It passed.
55% people voted to
reinstate the death penalty
three months before his trial.
Now the legislature
still had to act.
It wasn't a binding referendum
like you see in California.
And cooler heads
finally prevailed.
But that's an idea of what a
public sentiment and passions
can be.
Now, people who have watched the
documentary, even if you're not
convinced of Steven
Avery's innocence,
they recognize that there's
some real questions--
unanswered questions.
And they don't feel about
it the same way as they did.
And I use that as an example,
because now if judges only
acted as the conduits for that
kind of public passion, then
there would be no rule of law.
It would sway back and
forth with the winds as they
blow, rather than judges
applying the law as it should
be applied, notwithstanding
the pressures that they
get from the populace.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Just
to sidetrack off
of something you said
there, you mentioned
about the conversation and the
death penalty being brought up.
And I am curious, do
you think that that
was a motivating factor,
even prior to the case
seeing the courtroom, prior
to the press conference?
Did they look at this as, hey,
this is an opportunity where
we can get this
guy, and we can use
this to motivate this political
whirlwind around the death
penalty in Wisconsin?
JERRY BUTING: I don't know
that I would go that far.
I think it was a more
personal animus about him,
between him and the
Manitowoc County authorities.
I think once it hit
the media and became
a big, high publicity
case, the people
who had wanted all along to
bring back the death penalty
saw that as an
opportunity and seized
on it as an opportunistic
chance to try and do that.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Interesting.
To get back on track of what
we were talking about before,
you talked about the
populace and the winds
and the change of the populace.
That leads us right into
talking about juries,
which you've alluded before
that juries are a problem.
Jurors can become jaded.
And that can affect the
ability to make fair judgment
of justice in the room.
And I think we all
know in this audience
that sequestration from
information in today's age
is nearly impossible.
Are our peers still capable
of forming juries that
can deliver justice for us?
JERRY BUTING: Well,
I think that's been
a question for the ages.
If you go back at the
founding of our country,
we had all kinds of
pamphlets and many newspapers
that were scurrilous gossip
and unfounded rumors,
not unlike what you see on the
internet sometimes these days.
But it wasn't
electronically shared,
but it was still shared
pretty widely with people
who are potential jurors.
In small towns, you've always
had the gossip in the town
or at the beauty parlor or
the fence between the yard
where there's
things that are said
about somebody who then they may
later have to judge as jurors.
And that could
influence them, too.
So it's more widespread now
with the information age
and the digital age.
But does that mean
that we can't still
deal with it in our system?
And I think we still can.
But I think it takes more effort
by judges to ferret out people
who can't.
Not everybody can
be a good juror.
And even if you could be a
good juror in one kind of case,
you may not be well-suited
for this particular case
that you're brought in on.
And what you can't
do is just say,
I'll take the first
12 people who walk in,
and those are going
to be the jurors.
And no, we're not going
to ask any questions.
And some judges rush that whole
jury selection process through
so fast that you
end up with jurors
who really can't set aside.
The law has never
been that a juror
has to come in completely
ignorant of everything.
But what they have
to be able to do
is, whatever pretrial
information they've received,
they've got to be able to
truly and fairly set it
aside and understand
that what they heard
outside the courtroom
may not be true
and that what they have
to base their judgment on
is what's in the courtroom.
Now if you can't do
that, then you've
got to be honest about it
and say, I can't do that.
And a judge has to be
careful to try and ferret out
those people who really
aren't able to do it.
So in this case, for instance,
it came up late in the trial
that every day the judge
would tell-- the jury
was not sequestered
until deliberations.
And you can still do that.
You take away their
cell phones and when
they're in deliberations,
they're supposed to be cut off.
But in a long trial, it's
very hard to do that.
But they were told every day,
don't go on the internet,
don't do any computer
searches, don't watch any TV
or talk to anybody who's
trying to give you information.
And it came out, as the trial
went on, that one woman--
it turns out, her husband
was watching television
and telling her
everything that happened
after they left the courtroom
when the jury was supposed
to be out.
And there were legal issues.
And some evidence was excluded.
Some would later come in.
But all those things
that usually jurors
aren't supposed
to be focused on,
this juror's husband
was telling her.
Another one was saying
something like, yeah,
the judge always tells
us, don't search anything
on your computer, don't
do any internet searches.
But you can just
delete whatever you do.
They'd never know.
How would they ever know?
And another juror spoke up
and said, oh, no, no, no, you
don't understand, it's
never really deleted.
They can find it.
And then the guy
just turned ashen
and continued to deny it when
he was brought into the judge
and questioned by the judge.
One of the other jurors kind
of ratted that person out.
But we took a long
time searching
for jurors in that case.
But most of the
time, they don't.
And so if that
happens in our case--
if it happened in our
case, although our case was
higher publicity than a lot--
and that's the other thing
is the run of the mill trial
is not going to have
that much information
available on the internet or
social media talking about it.
So it is easier, I
think, to still get
jurors who are
uninfluenced and unexposed
to the kinds of information
that shouldn't be coming in
until they hear it in court.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Well,
it's interesting,
because that causes me to
think about "Making a Murder,"
this docudrama that was put
together after the fact.
And I question then,
is this helping
because it is showing us
the flaws and the cracks
in the system?
Or knowing now,
seeing the fallout
from this, seeing the
feedback that's come back in,
questions about items that
were omitted from the series,
is it a net positive,
because it's
bringing these things to light?
Or is it doing more
harm than good,
because now we're also
using another device that
is influencing the way
people are thinking,
influencing the way
people are interacting
with this particular case but
other cases that are similar?
JERRY BUTING: That's
a good question.
But I think on balance,
transparency is good.
And I think that
"Making a Murderer"
has done something really that
nothing else has ever done.
And it's really caused--
we have people here today
who are interested in justice
and what happens in
their courtrooms who
really didn't know anything
or care about it before.
Half the states don't
even allow, approximately,
cameras in the courtrooms.
And the federal courts don't
have cameras in the courtrooms.
I've been a big
advocate for them,
because it's transparency.
People need to see what goes on.
Those are
representatives of them.
Whether it's judges, whether
they elect them or not,
they're still
representing the people.
And corruption sort of
seeps in in the shadows.
If people are watching--
and that's one of the
reasons that we've
cherished a free press,
a free media for so long
is that they can expose
that kind of corruption.
So a documentary that sheds
light on how the justice
system works and doesn't work
and the kinds of things that
go on, I think is always
going to be positive.
There will be some naysayers.
And there'll be some potential
fallout that could potentially,
let's say, make people
lose faith in their system
altogether and cause
them to just despair.
It could unravel
things even further.
But I don't think anybody's can
say that this documentary was
done in an exploitative way.
There weren't any
reenactments of a crime.
And you can see the
difference between
a exploitative documentary
and something that's
just showing what happens
in a particular case.
And then thoughtful
people can take that
and discuss what
kinds of lessons
we can learn to apply in other
cases, in order to try and get
back to where justice should be.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: How do we
then address the omissions?
It is a finite amount of
time that you can actually
have in this
documentary, and there
were over 200 hours of
activity in the courtroom.
How do we address
then the things
that were not on there
that, whether intentional or
unintentional, still affect,
from certain perspectives,
a bias about what that
documentary is presenting?
JERRY BUTING:
Well, first of all,
any documentary still
comes from a point of view.
There's going to be
bias of some sort.
We're human beings, and
they're human beings.
I think they've been
unfairly portrayed
as being more biased than they
were by deliberately leaving
out very powerful pieces of
the prosecution's evidence.
That's simply not the case.
And the way I know that
is I had a front row seat.
I saw what was at issue.
Yeah, there's defense evidence
that wasn't in there, too.
But if you're sitting on
that jury, for instance,
the way you know what's really
important to the parties
is, how much time do they spend
in closing argument talking
about it?
And if you spend half a page--
which is all Ken Kratz
spent on his closing
argument on the sweaty
hood latch DNA thing--
then that tells you that really
wasn't that powerful piece
of evidence, or he would
have used it more and so
the same thing with
some of the other things
that he's been critical
about being left out.
I can tell you that the major
issues that the parties were
fighting about-- the bones, the
blood, the bullet, the key--
those are covered in the
documentary pretty well.
In fact, when I saw them do
that in a total of about 3
and 1/2 hours, I was thinking,
why do we take six weeks?
I could have been
home a lot earlier.
So they do try to
present the issues that
were most in dispute in as fair
and balanced way as possible.
The one way that you do
get a little bit more
of a defense flavor to it
is because we cooperated.
And they interviewed
us behind the scenes.
And they interviewed the Averys.
But the same opportunity
was given to the prosecutors
and to the police.
The victim's family, I
certainly don't fault them
for not wanting to
participate at all.
But they haven't been
critical of it either.
But for somebody who
had the opportunity
to participate and give
that other perspective,
we thought all along
that they were.
To then say, this is biased, you
left all this stuff out-- well,
you had a chance to try
and participate and give
some behind the scenes.
I think it would have been
interesting to see what
it was like for prosecutors
brainstorming and working on,
how are we going to present
this issue and that issue?
They chose not to do that.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA:
Interesting stuff.
I want to go back
to the core of what
we've been talking about so
far and by way of the Brendan
Dassey case.
And one of the things that you
had said in another interview
was that you were surprised to
the lengths which they would
go to get this conviction
out of this kid
and just bury him,
completely and totally.
My question is not about
those links necessarily,
but at the root of it, why?
Why are there prosecutors
and law enforcement officials
and people embedded in
the justice system that
are willing to go beyond
what even the law allows
to get that conviction?
Because that seems to be
a major source behind the
breaks that you talk
about in the book.
JERRY BUTING: Yeah.
And again, every case
is a little different.
But there is, I think, a little
bit more personal animus that
was motivating some of the
things that were done here.
Steven Avery had the audacity to
sue Manitowoc County officials
who he believed wrongly
convicted him and made him sit,
stole 18 years of his
life and, while doing so,
allowed the real rapist to go
off and rape somebody else.
And again, he's suing
them for $36 million.
And that's a huge sum of money
for a county of that size.
But it wasn't just the money
that was motivating this.
Again, if you think
about the cop,
we've all probably had some
kind of encounter with a police
officer who's cops
an attitude with you.
And if you mouth back to
them, you get their dander up.
They get really pissed.
And he was in the process of
doing much more than that.
He was in the process of
embarrassing these people--
not just the money, but to
embarrass them and expose
what they had done to public
view in a small community.
And they were going to do
anything that they could,
I think, to prevent that.
And that's kind of
the motivating thing
that I think was going on
in this particular case.
And in other cases,
it's less so.
One of the things that
the Dean talks about--
you see police.
There's a whole
spectrum of misconduct
from actually planting evidence
against somebody or planting
drugs on somebody
that you arrest.
And by the way, we
know it happens,
because there are
documented cases
all over the country,
all over the world where
police manufacture evidence.
That's the far extreme end.
Another might be just where they
come into court and they fudge.
Or they lie, and they say, Yeah,
I saw him throw those drugs--
throw something from
his body, and then
we went over and picked it up--
what we used to
call dropsy cases.
It's like, come on.
And he looked you in the eye,
he sees you're in uniform,
you're coming at him, and
right in front of you,
he takes drugs out and
drops them on the ground?
And yet, this is
what officers would
testify about all the time.
Now not all police
are like this.
Most of them,
thankfully, are not.
But in those kinds
of cases, they
think it's "the ends justify the
means" mentality that seeps in.
And they may think that the
person is a drug dealer.
And therefore, they
are going to bust them.
They don't think he's a
completely innocent person
that they're going after.
And so probably the majority of
these police misconduct cases
are ones where they
become convinced
that they know whether the
person is guilty or not.
And therefore, they're
going to help things along.
And that's easier
for most people
to understand than
the ones where
they have such a personal animus
that they're actually going
after somebody to get him.
And in this case, we wanted
them to call Brendan Dassey
as a witness at our trial.
We were ready for
that, because we
were convinced
that we could show
that jury that this
kid was subjected
to deliberate, coercive,
leading questions, feeding him
the facts, none of which fit.
And you can see
why they don't fit,
because he's trying
to guess at what
it is they want him to say.
And he guesses wrong.
But it's there.
That, by the way, is another
important transparency thing.
Just six months before
this Dassey interrogation,
the law was changed in
Wisconsin to make it mandatory
that all custodial
interrogations be videotaped
from beginning to
end with no breaks.
If there had not been
videotape of what happened,
those officers would
have come into court
and testified, the same way
that Ken Kratz did at the press
conference, giving a narrative
as if this kid had just--
it all flowed out of him from
being unburdened by guilt,
when you could actually
look at the videotape.
You could see that it
was nothing of the sort.
It's just these little
monosyllabic utterances.
And he's confused and
long, pregnant pauses.
So we were convinced that
we could persuade the jury
that the confession was
false and that the techniques
that they used were
coercive and took advantage
of a young, inexperienced, quiet
kid who had mental limitations
and that if they were willing to
go that far to try and turn him
against Steven Avery,
then everything else
was fair game, too.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: We do want to
leave time for the audience
to ask questions.
So if you guys can make your
way to the microphones now,
that'd be great and
get those prepared.
One of the best
parts about the book
is that it tells a grander
story outside of the story
that the Netflix
documentary tells.
And a lot of that is your story.
And you've prepared a piece
that you'd like to read for us.
So I would welcome
you to do that now.
JERRY BUTING: Yeah,
because I guess authors
are supposed to do that.
So I guess I have
to read something.
But I'm going to pick something
that is very personal to me.
It's not legal at all.
But it's in the book
for a number of reasons.
It's partly because I went
through this very serious
illness just a few years before
the Avery case came to me.
And part of the decision
on whether I would even
take the case hinged
on, how clear was I
from this very serious cancer?
And so I'm going to read
a little section about how
I discovered it and
learned about it,
and then I'll wrap up
quickly thereafter.
So this is in the
summer of 2001.
I noticed there was a lump
on my leg-- very small,
about the size of your knuckle--
painless, no reason to think
there was anything going on.
And it turned out to be a
tumor the size of my hand--
literally the tip of an iceberg.
And my wife persuaded me to
go to the doctor's office.
And I ended up in this
specialist's office.
We'd had the CT scan.
And I knew there was
something in there,
but I was still
hoping it was benign.
And so this is what happened.
"So I called the specialist
Dr. Hackbarth first thing
on Tuesday, but the next
available appointment
was on Tuesday of
the following week.
At home, I pulled out the
films and tried to read them.
Cross sections of
tissue in each leg--
dozens of thumbnail images
impossible to make sense of.
I was pretty sure
that I could see
some form in the right leg that
was not visible in the left.
Kathy and I scoured
websites for information."
Kathy's my wife.
"Sometimes these
growths were benign,
and surely, that would
be the case with me.
I felt fine.
As a matter of
fact, I was feeling
more fit and trim
after a beach vacation
than I'd had in a long time.
We were in modestly
hopeful state
as the appointment with
Dr. Hackbarth approached.
Even so, this time
Kathy was coming along.
As I'd learned before working
alongside her in court,
having her there
would do me good.
We arrived at the
orthopedic clinic
at Froedtert Hospital
in Milwaukee early.
Dr. Hackbarth took a quick
look at the lump on my leg,
then stuck the images
into the light box,
scanning them for a moment.
'We'll need to get a biopsy,
probably tomorrow,' he said.
'I can tell you right now, this
is almost certainly malignant.
It's a soft tissue sarcoma.
I'm guessing it's
one of two types,
and they're both
quite rare and lethal.
We used to just take people's
legs with amputation,
but we've gotten better at this.
We will try to save
your life and your leg,
but you will definitely have
a long year ahead of you with
various kinds of treatments.'
As I stood over his
shoulder, he went
through the individual images
that showed the abnormality.
And he pulled up a full-length
picture of both legs
that I hadn't noticed before.
The difference was stark.
I couldn't tell what was
me and what was tumor.
The growth ran so high up
my leg that an amputation
might involve not just
the leg but my hip, too.
In any event, Dr.
Hackbarth said he
was going to do everything
he could to avoid that.
Just then, he got paged
and gently excused himself.
'I'll let you guys talk
about it,' he said.
'I'll come back
in a few minutes.'
A sinkhole had opened
beneath our lives.
Our son Steven was nine.
Grace, our daughter, was seven.
'Don't panic,' I told Kathy.
'It's not definite
until the biopsy.'
Clear-eyed Kathy would have none
of my whistling in the dark.
'He knows already,' she said.
'That's why he's telling
us the other stuff.'
Then Dr. Hackbarth opened
the door with an expression
on his face that hadn't been
there a few minutes earlier.
It was now about 10:30
AM Milwaukee time.
'That page was from my
wife,' he said slowly.
'A plane has hit the World Trade
Center, and it's collapsed.'
At first, Kathy and I gave
each other a look that said,
this guy's nuts,
let's get out of here.
But as we talked
further, it became clear
that Dr. Hackbarth
was telling the truth.
In the car on the way
home, the radio broadcasts
were full of one alarming
piece of news after another.
A second plane had hit
the other Twin Tower.
The Pentagon had also been hit.
Nobody knew where the
president's plane was.
People were in bunkers.
A plane had gone
down in Pennsylvania.
The government had
ordered all airliners
to land and not to fly
again until further notice.
This was a horrible
national tragedy.
I felt awful for everybody.
Kathy and I had been in New
York less than a year earlier
for another NACDL conference.
We went to the World Trade
Center and ate at the Windows
on the World.
And yet, I couldn't
help but think
that I was going to be
dead in a few months.
I was 45 years old, and
until now, I had not
given mortality much thought.
I was absorbed by Kathy, by the
two little kids in our lives,
and by work.
What had I done to leave
my mark on the world?
My life had been a
meaningless blip."
So I often sometimes wonder--
I'm a person of faith.
I believe in God.
I'm Catholic, born and raised.
I sometimes wonder, why did
I make it through illness?
And maybe it was so that I
could do a case like this,
have all of these
things develop,
and become a
spokesperson for justice.
And who knows?
And I had a long,
hard year and two
years of learning how to walk
again with physical therapy.
And ultimately, I took the case.
Kathy convinced me I was ready.
Dean was confident
I could do it.
And I never regretted that.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Fantastic.
JERRY BUTING: All right.
So--
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: I'd
like to open it up
to questions from the audience.
Why don't we begin over?
AUDIENCE: Wow, heavy stuff.
But let me try my
question out anyway.
So in the case you
described with Steven Avery,
it does sound like
there was certainly
a degree of actual
malicious prosecution.
But the other half of the broken
justice system you described
seems to be more broad
strokes, like the overworking,
overburdening of the court
system, disenfranchisement
of minorities, over
populated prisons--
stuff like that.
And I'm certainly sympathetic
to that point of view.
I feel it's broken as well.
But I was wondering
if you could perhaps
take your lawyerly skills
to advocate for what
seems to be
indefensible, and maybe
describe some of the
good intentions that
brought our justice
system to this place.
What are the
motivations that might
have created these super
long sentences or the changes
in how prosecutors treat the
courtroom and stuff like that?
JERRY BUTING: Well, OK.
It's certainly
understandable why
people feel like we need to
have these real long sentences.
Let's take that one
first for a second here.
What happens is
there is something
that's been documented in the
literature-- something called
a moral panic.
And in this context, you see
it when there's a particularly
heinous crime that happens--
some young girl is
murdered brutally
and killed by somebody, and
maybe he's been in prison
and gotten out.
And he's like a serial killer
or a serial rapist or something.
And we then react
with moral outrage
and want to increase
penalties and make--
well, how did this guy get
out in the first place?
And if he would
have been locked up,
this never would have
happened, and we should just
have longer sentences,
and we should
make it mandatory so judges
don't have any discretion.
And the problem is, it's
a one-size-fits-all type
of remedy that's based on cases
that are really pretty rare.
There were something like
20 million new charges
filed last year alone.
And the percentage
of them that are
those types of cases that really
cause and deserve moral outrage
are very, very small.
So to try and apply what
you need in those few cases
to everything, it may
start off well-intentioned,
but then it ends up screwing
up the whole system when
you do that.
Another example is sex
offender registration.
The idea of registering
people as sex offenders, which
is like the Scarlet
Letter of 21st century--
the idea was that,
well, if there's
a person that's living down
the block from my children who
is a sex offender,
I should know that.
And in theory, that's
fine, except for it ignores
the reality, which is that
95% of child sex offenses
occur from not a
stranger down the block
that you don't know
about but from somebody
that you know very well--
the uncle or the neighbor--
the next door neighbor
who's close to the
family, not a stranger,
or the stepdad or whatever.
And so having
somebody registered
as a sex offender does
nothing to protect you
in those situations.
So they started off
with a good idea
that, yeah, for the most
serious kinds of sex offenders,
we're going to
have them register.
And then you can know
if somebody really
is a potential-- one of
the stranger abduction-type
offenders in your neighborhood.
You should know that, right?
But then politicians, in
order to try and act tougher
and tougher and get
elected and re-elected,
they started expanding the
kinds of crimes that fit
the definition of a sex offender
for registration purposes,
to the point where even two
teenagers who are having
consensual sex but under
age, therefore illegal--
and usually, it's the guy
who gets convicted-- now
is a registered sex offender.
The people that you should
really care about and be
afraid of are just a handful.
But when you go on the website,
there's something like--
it's between 25,000 and 50,000
people on that registry now,
the vast, vast majority
of whom are not a risk
to the public as a whole.
So what happens to them?
Now the hysteria has
gotten even worse.
And now we don't even want
them living in neighborhoods
or in communities.
So towns are passing ordinances
saying, you can't live,
if you are on that
list, within 2,000
feet of a school or a
park or a shopping center
or any place where
kids can congregate.
And as you started drawing
the radiuses around that,
the city of Milwaukee--
almost the entire city limits
are off-limits for anybody who
is on that list, to the point
where there are now over 300
homeless people who are on that
list who cannot live any place
in the city of Milwaukee.
You're not allowed to
move anywhere else either.
Other counties say, oh, if you
were convicted in Milwaukee,
you got to come
back to Milwaukee.
And it's so insane that--
this is a story.
It was in the newspaper
just a couple of months ago.
Parole agents are
saying that you're not
allowed to reside
in the city, so
go stay with your
mother for a few days.
Don't live there.
Don't put your clothes there.
And then go park your car
in the park-and-ride lot
and live out of your
car for a few days.
And then drive, and go stay at
your sister's for a few days.
It's just this shell game
that, again, started off
with an idea that
maybe was valid
but then got exploded out
of all sense of reason
by politicians,
really, who were just
trying to act tough on crime.
I don't know if that
answered all your question,
but it gives you a few ideas.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: And I think
we have time for another one.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
As a defense attorney,
how far do you
go to try to understand if your
client is guilty or innocent?
And how does your belief
in their guilt or innocence
change your defense strategy?
JERRY BUTING: Good
questions, both.
It shouldn't change your
defense strategy, because most
of the time, you don't know.
Well, first of all, the
vast majority of people,
if they're guilty, they
tell you they're guilty.
And they want you to help them.
They admit they screwed up.
Whatever their
wrongdoing was, but can--
so it's the job of
the defense attorney
to humanize that person
and let the judge know
that whatever they did,
it's a snapshot of them.
It's not the whole person.
You've got to look beyond that.
Look at all the other things
they've done in their lives.
They've been a good father,
or they pay child support--
whatever it might be.
But the role of a
defense attorney
is not really to make the
judgment about whether or not
somebody is guilty.
And I'm just going
to tell the story.
It's in the book.
But I alluded to earlier.
And since you brought it up,
here's the perfect example.
When I was a public defender, I
had been there for about eight,
almost nine years.
We were under so
much pressure, we
had to open 15 new
felony cases a month.
And there was no case
waiting at that time.
We had to open those
cases, whether we
had closed a single one or not.
And my caseload was enormous.
And a first degree
homicide that was
going to take a month
to try or longer,
like the Avery case,
counted as one felony,
just the same as a garage
burglary where a bike is stolen
and the kid's going
to get probation.
And he's what we would
call an easy case.
And so I started
triaging these cases
when we would get them by
going through intake court
and meeting them
for the first time.
Really, all you're
supposed to do
is figure out what the
bail is and give the judge
some information
for setting up bail.
But I would read the complaints.
And I would try and see, OK,
this one is going to be easy.
This one is going to be hard.
I can only take a few
hard ones this month,
because I've got these other
big cases set for trial.
And I needed to fill my
quota of some easy ones.
So I'm reading
this one, and this
looks like a piece of cake.
It's a burglary.
He's caught red-handed.
He's inside this
apartment building.
And so I read it over
real quick to him.
And is this true?
He's like, no, man, it's not
true, I'm completely innocent.
And he tells me this story
that's a ridiculous story.
It's a complete cock and ball.
There's no way.
And I'm thinking, OK, so this is
going to be a pain in the ass.
I'm going to have
to try this case.
It's going to take
me several days.
So I come back to the office.
And I was real tired.
I'd had like 25
or 30 cases I ran.
So some of them weren't
going to have to keep.
And my friend at that
time-- later, wife--
Kathy said, how was your day?
And I said, well, it sucked.
And there's this
guy, for instance.
And he tells me this
ridiculous story.
And I told it to her.
And she said, well,
I'll take that case.
I said, well, go ahead,
knock yourself out.
So she did.
She got an investigator.
She determined he was
telling the absolute truth.
His cock and bull
story was true.
He was innocent, 100%.
Case was dismissed.
And that taught me a lesson.
That kind of thing happens
thousands of times a day
all over the country with
overworked defense attorneys.
And I started
thinking, if that's
the way I feel about
a client-- if I'm
making those kinds of snap
judgments in the first three
minutes, is that going to
affect the way I can really--
the effort I'm going to
put in and the way I'm
going to defend him or her?
And so that
ultimately taught me I
had to get out of the
public defender's office.
But it was also a lesson
in why you can't--
as a defense attorney,
it's not your role
to make those judgments,
particularly early on,
because it could shade the
way you investigate or not.
Maybe I wouldn't even have
gotten an investigator,
because the story was so absurd.
Anybody else?
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: We are running
a little short on time,
so we do need to wrap up.
But before, I just
have one last question.
We've touched a lot on all
the breaks in the system.
And unfortunately, this is going
to be one of those questions
that we could talk for
another hour about.
But I want to ask, what
are some of the fixes
that we should be looking
for or that are in process--
things like the
Innocence Project, things
that are looking into these
breaks in the system--
what are some of the things
that we need to be aware of,
of how we can fix
what's going on?
JERRY BUTING: OK.
And I do spend some time
in the book towards the end
and talking about some
solutions and things we can do.
One of the things we can do that
everybody can do individually
is really start to take
ownership of your own court
system.
Don't just be worried about
what happened in a distant state
10 years ago or the Avery case.
But care about what goes on
in your own court system.
Now that's not easy,
because everybody works.
And you can't go sit
down in a court house
and look at who's doing
a fair job and who's not.
But if you have a chance
to vote for a judge
or a sheriff or a
prosecutor, often those
are in off elections.
So many people don't vote.
Maybe 10% or 20%,
at most, end up
voting for judges
and prosecutors
and sheriffs who have an
enormous amount of power
in the system.
And you can make a difference.
Just in the last
year, voters threw out
prosecutors in Cleveland,
Chicago, Jacksonville who
had run traditionally
on, I'm just
going to get tough
on crime, I'm going
to lock people up and
throw away the keys--
the clanging cell
door kind of TV ads.
When you see those kinds of
appeals, don't fall for it.
If anything, maybe vote for
somebody who's not doing that.
That's enough alone if you
don't even know the two people.
But if you can educate
yourself by talking
to people who are lawyers
and then exercise your right
to vote, you should, because
that's your way to, other
than a jury--
well, here's one other thing.
If you get a jury
summons, don't just think
it's like a root canal
that you have to do.
It's the one chance
you have a way
to actually participate directly
in your judicial system.
But be honest when you're
going through jury selection.
If it's a case that's
troubling you--
your best friend was
sexually assaulted
and you just can't put that
aside if it's a sexual assault
case, then be honest
about it and just say,
I'd like to be fair,
but I don't think I can.
And you'll see other things.
If there are legislators
who are championing things
like mandatory videotape
recordings of interrogations,
you need to get behind that.
There are organizations,
by the way,
that work on all different
little issues that
are a problem in the
criminal justice system.
And those are just
a few of them.
Crime labs, lack of independence
is another serious one.
The city of Austin,
Texas just discovered
that their crime
lab, for years, had
been using wrong data and
unscientific procedures.
They shut down the whole thing.
The police wanted to reopen it.
And they had to send
their four DNA--
or I'm sorry-- six DNA analysts
to this state-run re-training
program.
And four of them were
kicked out they were so bad.
They failed.
So ultimately,
now there's a move
to make the crime
labs more independent
so that they can do real science
and not just get the results
that the police want.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Well, there's
a lot more in the book.
Unfortunately, we
are out of time.
The book is called
"Illusion of Justice."
It's a great expansion on to the
story of "Making a Murderer."
Thank you so much for
being with us here today.
JERRY BUTING:
You're very welcome.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: I really
appreciate it, Jerry.
JERRY BUTING: Thank you.
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]